hello Steve Goffman here um on my blog
which is called the linguist on language
I posted recently on the subject first
of all I was comparing different
language system I was at systems I was
asking people to comment on how they
found link versus light mocha versus
mango versus different podcasts and I
got a lot of interesting responses and I
really appreciate that and some people
appreciated the fact that we have longer
contents at least for our intermediate
and advanced learners but I want to what
I want to talk about today and some
people said yes link is great but it's
better for an intermediate and more
advanced learners because of the nature
of our content I guess because of our
system but can you learn from scratch
and so it raises this whole issue of how
do you learn a language starting from
zero and my advice used to be and I
think this was the advice that I have in
my book is that you know and what I
would do is I would go out and I would
buy a teach yourself whatever Norwegian
and then I would buy what else was it
that two or three other systems
colloquial is another one Pimsleur maybe
I'm gonna have my little evening
cocktail here and so then I would cover
more or less the same material in two or
three different books and basically what
I was looking for in these books was
content easy content a little bit of
vocabulary that's there lots of
explanation which I kind of leaf through
and don't pay much attention to but the
main thing is that I would listen to
lesson one through lesson 20 in say
teach yourself and then I would go back
to actually I never did like Pimsleur
because all of their sound files
contain so much English which is not the
way I study I prefer to listen only to
the target language and then I read the
vocabulary list so CEM sir wouldn't be
one but I see meal which is the French
system so I would listen to these
different systems coming more or less
the same content and what I liked was
when there was continuity in the content
so lesson one is maybe 20 30 seconds
long if it's Korean it's hello mr. Kim
how are you hello my name is mr. Lee
that's kind of lesson 1 and I liked it
when there is continuity very often
there was one of the worst books was
living language where they had no sort
of little dialogues at all they just had
a collection of phrases but that's
that's impossible to learn from in my
mind because I like to have episodes I
like to in my mind if I can find the
words in an overall context which is
meaningful it's easier for me to listen
again and again it's easier for me to
remember the words so I often give that
advice and people come to the link and
they say it's too difficult I can't
figure out what to do if I'm if I'm
starting from scratch from zero so I was
thinking about this and I said well
maybe I should just tell people go out
and buy a teach yourself and colloquial
whatever Portuguese and when you've gone
through those two books which should
take a month or two of just listening
then come to link but then I thought to
myself you know I bought a book teach
yourself Romanian but you know I started
going through it and each chapter
teaches different parts of speech and I
have no desire to go to that book and we
have a link we have three stories or
three content collections which exist in
all 10 languages
we have one that's called eating out we
have one that's called greetings and
goodbyes and one that's called who is
she which is a bit of a detective story
that I wrote in 26 episodes I know who
is she very well because that's what I
used for my beginner Russian I listened
to it 30 40 50 times and of course I
knew the story very well because I had
written it and we have these now in all
languages and I think that today I would
recommend rather than starting in two
explanations of the grammar and some
explanation of how to pronounce the
language and where to put your tongue
and so forth just start in with a little
story that you already know and so I
think my advice now is that that I think
our link method works very well for
beginners if people are prepared to
understand our philosophy which is just
listen and get used to language your
first month until you're just getting
over that initial strangeness of the
language and acquiring some vocabulary
no it's much more difficult if the
language is Chinese or Japanese where we
have a whole other issue which is the
characters so in other words you cannot
read it phonetically you cannot read the
text phonetically and because both
Chinese and Japanese is still in beta we
eventually want to have it so that we
would have characters and pinyin for
Chinese or romaji for Japanese and kana
and also the the choice of putting the
the translation in your own language all
in the same page we don't have that
right now it's a little bit awkward you
would have to go and open up the english
version of who is she and have that open
in a separate tab while you're looking
at the say russian version of who is she
and listening to it but getting back to
Romanian if I were going to try to learn
Romanian today I think I would rather
have someone translate who is she 26
episodes 30 minutes and I would go
through all of that and it's it
gradually gets more and more
I would learn the words and that that
would keep me busy for two months if I
did who is she and then if I did eating
out and if I did those three simple
stories now I am NOT a writer I mean I
wrote my book on language learning you
know it would be great if some of our
members at Lake would create some more
simple simple stories that we can then
have our members translate into
different languages thirty seconds to
begin with getting up to a minute long
simple stories hopefully with a bit of a
some element of suspense so that the
person is motivated to read on to the
next episode but certainly having them
connected so that each one initially is
very short and if someone commented on
my blog they don't like reading or
learning from small short disjointed
content out of that but if you have 30
seconds and you download that and pretty
soon it just flows and you don't know
where lesson one ended listen to begin
because it's a whole it's a story so if
we can get our members to write some
more simple stories if we have maybe
five or six ten no more stories each one
15 20 episodes long which existed in ten
languages because some people are more
interested in this or that or something
else then that's how I would recommend
beginners learn now the problem is
people don't understand our way of
learning people want explanations people
want to hear it in their own language
and so we might also consider having a
very simple explanation of the fact that
your brain will pick it up just let your
brain listen to it focus on increasing
your words your vocabulary get a lot of
input in you try to enjoy it don't be
afraid of it don't worry about
reproducing the line
which you don't have to be able to you
know say something right away a lot of
these language systems they they promise
you that you'll be speaking in two weeks
and so forth well he won't be no matter
what you do and probably if you were
able to say hello how are you and where
is the bathroom that you wouldn't
understand the answer anyway so on this
business of what should beginners do I
used to recommend that they go out by
three different startup books and and
that might still be a solution for some
people because then a Dutch person can
get Dutch explanation and the Chinese
person gets Chinese explanation or if
you'll trust our system just go in
listen to something very simple
get it up on another tab in your
language listen to it in the target
language read it in your language a few
times you never got me used to this
thing to it a little bit now read it in
the target language hopefully it's not
Chinese or Japanese for you there's no
connection between the sound and what
you see start saving words and phrases
and pretty soon you're on your way at
least that's what I would recommend and
five